[Music]
did you guys hear about Starbucks
closing 400 locations across the u.s.
and Canada over the next 18 months I do
tip because I was going to invest in
Starbucks talks and now I'm going to
wait until they hit bottom to invest in
Starbucks talks they had two mini
endemic
so the thing is that they usually like
they do closed about like a hundred
every year like it's normal like they'll
close a whole bunch of stores over here
but this time it's 400 which is a lot
more than their usual numbers and also
they they expect as much as 3.2 billion
dollar reduce in sales gonna be losing
3.2 billion dollars this morning yes we
did we hoped we did our part every
morning that's why I'm still gonna buy
stocks I'm just waiting for them to hit
bottom because I think they'll pull
through they always do
there's too many Starbucks though hell
yeah there's a Starbucks next to a
Starbucks yeah there really is like
three from each other and then in the
grocery store yeah it isn't like we
don't need that many in ours in our city
there's a Starbucks in that same Plaza
there's a Vons and in that Vons there's
a Starbucks in the quads and then across
the street and then like over it like
one more block there's another but
haven't you ever been in line at a
Starbucks and [ __ ] out the door and
you're like I wish there was another
store every time see order and then I go
straight to the mobile and there's a
line there too yeah those lines are to
none
did you know like the okay so before
this pandemic happened they said that
they were already planning on rolling
out these these certain locations called
Starbucks pick up where the its sole
purpose is just for you to go in and
pick up from your mobile orders like
either through overeats or through the
apps the Starbucks app and so they had
already had these plans for a long time
because they had found that
approximately 80% of US transactions are
to go orders so they really ready
is there any like the trend of what like
the consumer [ __ ] force and they know
that cuz like you go to any Starbucks
and they have like four tables max like
it's yeah well cuz the guy's got his
[ __ ] laptop and half of them and
that's the thing about the pickup thing
a guy I know guys gonna show up and try
to plug in so ultimately shutting down
400 decreases their rent costs and like
all that all that overhead so they can
make smaller yeah mobile pick up
stations yes and they're also they're
saying that these pick up stations
they're gonna be mere a regular
Starbucks cafe like they're it's like
it's supposed to work okay then that's
weird again I'm gonna make it and then
like rollerblade those things
sonic yeah no sorry
I hope the pick up ones aren't
drive-through I do really like
drive-through another part of it because
of the pandemic they are looking into
more places you don't have drive-through
like all these 400 stores they're not
gonna be the ones that walk in one only
yeah I don't know how those ones made it
this far the walk in one less and less
interaction that society you know
continues with like all the
screenwriters go to look cool like
there's green riding now going to the
hipster yeah they don't participate in
Starbucks consumption dude was at
McDonald's on I think is victory that
was only net no drive-through and it
[ __ ] closed and I was like that's the
free market baby I bless you cuz then
nobody wants to go into a McDonald's I
hate going into story I only look for a
drive-through places like there will be
if there's a McDonald's Jeremy and
actually I don't think I've come across
a McDonald's that doesn't have factor
but if I would I would literally just
get back in my app and search for
another one that does have birth the
temperature goes back to - Utley like
this pandemic is like getting people
more used to not going plays
turning into Wally yeah we're getting
closer and closer to Raleigh I we're
getting fat we're
that all the clothes are shifting to
comfortable oh that's what all this
loungewear [ __ ] I'm like hell yes the
best jeans I've been boycotting jeans
for years yeah I only wear jeans what I
have I'm scared to go back into G's cuz
that's gonna show me that I can do it
yeah jeans are not your friend baby
hello geo nice to see you again try me
on I'll show you what's worth try me
let me punish you how come sweatpants
haven't taken over the [ __ ] world
they have they just gotta read a
different form so now they're like loli
cause like at the leisure yeah joggers
but I would been wrong if I would have
bought as soon as sweatpants came out
what about all the stock my sweatpants
I'm like these are gonna kill jeans like
khakis is done I was wrong
people had to go to work and that's
what's changing not having to go to work
yes really don't need jeans nearly as
much or tucking your shirt in I do wish
they made back pockets on sweat stone
barn yes and zippers all the time I'm
not so many airplanes just defend
yourself for then like I did because you
looked at me and I just have it's
something about you made me be honest
okay I do so many airports go mini air
pods because my sweats don't have
pockets yeah have zippers and you sit
down and they fall out out and then
they're gone
I got some joggers with zippers it's the
best yeah but then you don't have it in
the back it's too much stuff in the side
pocket well you need more pot pocket so
you could spread them out so Super Bowls
gonna sit on it yeah I have to sit on my
wallet I heard you're not supposed to
but I don't know what else to do that it
like messes up your posture that's when
I heard about your wallet gets really
big what if you all make sure you have
equal money than in you actually don't
really need your wallet for much anymore
yeah you might won't have my B I have
like pictures of my beer
I do this thing yeah it's all the follow
steps we did let you just show your ID
what I'm not flying I do that's it yeah
what of all your club cars just travel
with this and I'm ready to run where's
your chapstick in soy sauce packet you
put in a pocket always has one soy sauce
packet in her sauce
Oh random like poking like not know
where that comes from
she never it's never poets never poked
it only seems a day I would say today
Tabasco sauce bottle on a keychain and
it broke oh not a good invention see via
one of those shitty like tourist stores
oh it was very tiny okay for your first
birthday that we were together I got
like a bunch of things that reminded me
of Steve so I got balloons and Colts
colors because Kohl's is his favorite
team and I tied the the weights for the
balloons with a little Tabasco bottles
and then I got him a cake with a monkey
on it because he loves monkeys and it
was in a time monkey he loves when
monkeys are wearing human clothes and
pretending to like go to work and [ __ ]
so I got that on the cake and then I had
it if you have a monkey wearing a suit
he's got a little briefcase I'm [ __ ]
laughing everything yeah same thing with
kids that's something Robin Williams
would love I don't know why that was
random do you go online and look up
monkeys in human oh yeah so he's like
using a banana as a phone and he's got
his worksheet on you see the monkey with
the typewriter he throws it of course
amazing have you seen the monkey walking
around smoking a cigarette like he's a
person
yeah it's great he's like doing a human
impression he was like the first monkey
comedian like you know they could rip
off your face and like they even like
the little finger monkeys have you seen
those so cute but they'll eat your ears
off and listen to her monkey the spider
monkey no they this is a diaper that's
what I got --boom guys change your
diaper break well the movie outbreak
that it was that spider-man all right is
the monkey from friends a spider monkey
talking about ourselves I think oh that
guy looks friendly too yeah that's the
chimp though chimps are very friendly
looking monkey so Michael Jackson had
all right bubbles to go Steve
[Laughter]
my friend was he was gonna open a
restaurant that was ubereats only cuz he
was he was like he realized that most
people it's just a kitchen pretty much
yeah just a commercial kitchen
no no overhead for waitstaff or anything
like that so it could be a lot smaller
and he was saying how most people go on
overeat they never actually go and check
what the restaurant looks like they just
check the reviews yeah that's true and I
was like Dan you [ __ ] up restaurant no
no no no nothing you can't you can only
order on overeats impulse mates endure
it could be like that I don't even need
to be in a commercial area it can be
that Glee industrial to be in the back
of a warehouse back warehouse because
nobody cares as long as it's near people
or the restaurant yeah but you don't
like most restaurants are designed to be
near people which makes the real estate
more but if like say this place was a
kitchen you know as long as it passed
the help code
he doesn't have to be near if you just
be of an apartment yeah well it has to
be zoned as a real estate though our
commercial is take our short daddy
commissary you're not taking in the
middle of warehouses everyone true dude
what's gonna happen a commercial real
estate it's gonna change right because
all these big companies are realizing
they don't actually have to have their
employees come in they didn't have to
for for a long time but you know we're
so resistant to change we're like we
gotta come in from 9:00 to 5:00 we have
to have an office we have to have a
secretary at the front but you don't
have to though like with technology like
we haven't had to firm you can't you can
you could deposit a check with your
phone it goes it's the best thing ever
is that insane as soon as the event that
should I was like I'm doing any needed
it was the best thing it's hard to keep
track though dude cuz I don't like
throwing them away
I never told and I'm like it's hard to
keep track of which ones I already put
in I put the little chap yeah there's a
check mark on the back I didn't trust it
for so long or simply just write the
date on the front I used to do that and
they used to tell me oh you know you can
use the ATM to put your check in and I
was like yeah right I'm not doing that
[ __ ] every [ __ ] time you wait in that
lucky store right jex huh no not anymore
no I got accepted at I I've been taking
pictures of checks now look do you write
checks he doesn't no no no [ __ ] no I
don't write checks I mean you seem like
the type no well he's not allowed to go
near the textbooks I can't I can't touch
it is he we're just gonna keep it
playing yeah we have a certain amount of
money sauces if I'm gonna spend a
certain amount of money I have to clear
what I have to clear with the financial
really yeah what's like 500 bucks no way
yeah yeah so anything under 500 you
could buy a multiple time sure but yeah
that's my unless my loophole there's a
frequency back back
with my statements like every couple of
days and I'm like what's this I was just
like what's it say he's like that's a
cryptocurrency I was like okay yeah
that's good yeah cuz we don't want to do
that because then I'm gonna get a
[ __ ] headache something you bought
[ __ ] 40 glowstick what we do is we
have I have my account he has his
accountant then we have our joint
account so the joint account stuff it's
joint decisions got it if you're a
really good husband like me and you're
buying chem-lights for the family or
glowsticks for the family I still bought
with my own money possible families to
share that's her her dad's a CPA so she
was raised with all this [ __ ]
knowledge about all this stuff and I was
raised by white trash people who
literally think that they won the
Publishers Clearing House yesterday they
did vacation I literally thought they
won the boiler is clearly won the
Publishers Clearing House one of
Mercedes Benz CRI they're coming at four
o'clock in the afternoon we give the big
check we won the 2.5 million and it's
like oh my god guys it's a scam like and
they don't know that they're like it's
it's so cute
yeah so that's you know I was not that
I'm horrible at this [ __ ] but she's so
[ __ ] Ginsu good at it than am i a
month ago what were you doing before oh
brother I RS a lot of money yeah I RS
like 13 G's sure yeah yeah thankfully
her dad was able to help me figure out
how to pay it off [ __ ] the right way
cuz I was [ __ ] for a little bit from
the notice right now we're working on
building his credit so why I had bad
credit cuz I give an extra credit Cardin
Oh
[Music]